hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am here it's
your girl jacine Mr Mark Ellis we are
both fresh off of the Big Apple it was
good the Big Apple we had very different
accommodations mine were fine I enjoyed
my hotel just dandy but then when I
heard where jacn was staying my I look I
try not to get jealous of people I'm
pretty good at staying um you know it
within myself and not being envious and
not coveting others possessions but when
you're staying in a hotel that Jack and
was staying at I couldn't help but ask
many many many follow-up questions this
is the Dream Hotel I've always wanted to
be at this is so funny so Mark and I
were both in New York for a New York
ComicCon he was doing standup I was up
there moderating the Blum Fest panel
with universal and they put me up and
this is the thing like I don't know what
hotel I'm going to they send me an
itinerary they tell me where to go I
would have known from the address I've
studied this place but I got to be in
the Hudson yard's Equinox hotel which
Mark is a member of the Equinox Gym I'm
not okay let I want to get the take of
Cinema Joe here he's our special guest
you know from the house of Cinema
podcast you can follow him on social
media huge channels you see them on Tik
Tok all the time Cinema Joe the nicest
place you've ever stayed the nicest
hotel you've ever been in uh not the
Hudson yard I'll tell you that much
Equinox that's legendary status which by
the way I felt so bad I was like list I
know we're about to go on this tangent
but I forgot he had set this up already
like he told me he's like it's been at
the Forefront of my brain ever since I
found out cuz again it meant a lot more
to him but no Joe thank you so much for
joining us today thank you for listening
to my Equinox rant I felt so bad for him
just like let me tell you about what me
and Mark basically had an entire I
wouldn't say drink conversation about
but you were just we were having a bage
and talking about I feel like Cinema
Joe's at least done like a a Four
Seasons yeah yeah there's been a couple
nice hotels in New York I went to last
which favorite New York Hotel oh I
couldn't tell I've been in New York
twice in my life it was you know there
on courtesy of somewhere else's dime
they put me there I was it was very nice
you want to go State Equinox you and I
can split it yeah we can do that you're
going be there like honestly now that I
think that I've been there you're going
to have to be there just so you could
say you could also have been there and
the legend of Mark Ellis will continue
cuz that's right ladies and gentlemen
our movie today is the 1985 classic not
the Tom Hardy movie that it gets
confused with nowadays but the 1985
Ridley Scott starring Tom crew
Epic Fantasy tale Legend it is our film
today that Rotten Tomatoes wants to say
is wrong it is ranked as the 35 best of
the 80s fantasy movies that is despite
the 42% rotten score but the 73%
audience score which I think is a little
bit more accurate the number one moving
off of that one is The Princess Bride to
give you an idea of sort of the stuff
that folks are interested in that it's
also included in our book Rotten movies
Rel love under not their best work or
they've or so they've said you know this
is definitely the one that Ridley Scott
doesn't necessarily go behind there's so
much to go about that Mark Sir um I'm
going to start with you cin Joe what's
your history a little bit with Legend
like I have to know a little bit is this
a is this a movie you had a particular
affinity for I went through a phase my
my my childhood where I was watching a
lot of fantasy like a lot of people did
you know a lot of medieval a lot of
fantastic cool movies Legend was in the
Run of movies I would watch and revisit
but probably on the bottom half of the
list of movies I'd watch and revisit now
there's some other movies I would
constantly watch and that came around
around the same time Princess Bride As
you mentioned earlier was number one
that I yeah it's fantasy it's not the
same though I don't think it's the same
sword and sandal it's like the sword and
sandle type Vibes as I like to say you
know what I mean where there may be
dragons but there's definitely like
Warriors and knights yeah I me I feel
like I was in the same world watching
this movie which I just came to last
night I'd never seen it before so I'm
coming to this movie and like I see the
world it takes place in and I can see
another continent in this on this planet
where you're going to have like the
medieval King Arthur kind of stuff going
on and then maybe you have like The Land
Before Time somewhere else and you have
what my fantasy movie that I grew up
watching in my rotation which
unfortunately is at the very bottom of
our Rotten Tomatoes list the 35 best
1980s fantasy movies Caravan courage and
Ewok Adventure that was one I was I mean
OB I was a big Star Wars kid but the two
Ewok movies solid rotation they got
solid air time the that was very age
appropriate it was more battle for Endor
less Caravan courage but Caravan courage
sound Caravan courage just doesn't the
name doesn't sound as as exciting as
battle for Ewoks battle for Endo was
like oh my God that's the place from
Return to the Jedi we got protected at
all cost caravana courage sounds like
we're getting the family into the
minivan and we're going to go to
Grandma's it doesn't sound as like
dangerous you know what and you need d
for you to feel like you're really this
genre I want my to be in a little bit of
not not a lot a little bit of peril and
this is one of those movies that I will
say this was part of that like scary
fantasy movie this was like you know a
little Never Ending Story for me when I
caught it obviously not specific to the
time frame because literally I think I
was two but the movie itself was a part
of that you know Return to Oz L uh
definitely uh The Never Ending Story
secret of the Nim all of those sort of
like fantasy scary-ish kids movies that
you still really wanted to watch and so
I would appreciate it Mark if you could
take I want you to make sure you
appreciate how scary this movie is cuz
they're like killing stuff in the first
opening scene well that's why I'm glad I
didn't see it as a kid like like like
Joe did because I I think a lot of the
darkness sort of stuff and like the
minions of Darkness would have actually
like scared the crap out of me it's it
it's one of the things I it's one of the
big qualities of this movie is how
imposing our our villainous presence has
looked yes so if you don't mind sir give
us exactly what the villainous presence
was in this one and there's so many we
haven't even discussed we haven't even
tipped the iceberg of the names dates
and events of this one so please let's
let's find out what happens no you have
this demon known as Darkness the
darkness not the the fun rock band from
the early 2000s it's still going strong
uh Tim Curry playing Dark an
unrecognizable Tim Curry unless you
really know Tim's voice which obviously
a lot of us do now uh that's sort of the
villainous Presence counteracted by all
these wonderful unicorns that at least
there's a couple around and they're the
keepers of light and they have it within
themselves and so as long as the
unicorns maintain the breathing and then
they don't go to the glow Factory then
good then we have a balance in the world
unfortunately now we got some
humanish interaction with the unicorns
and that kind of offsets our action
where uhoh we got to protect the
unicorns now we might have gone too far
thanks to the princess played by Mia
Sarah and the forest boy known as Jack
kind of kind of a mowgly situation a
little bit he just kind of seems to make
his home outdoors and we have some Elves
that come in and chime in we have a lot
going on in here but basically we have
to raise an Army full of elves and we
have to stop Darkness from killing the
Last Unicorn uh because then the world's
going to be an eternal night and as much
as you and I enjoy the city that never
sleeps occasionally you do want to see
the sun come up so it's stopping
Darkness it's stopping evil from taking
over and more importantly Jack I think
he's really sweet on this Lily girl
played by Mia Sarah played by Mia Sarah
from Ferris bu's Fame thank you and time
cop she's great in time cop she's also
great in time cop definitely one of the
it girls of the 80s thank you so much
for that synopsis Cinema Joe sir if you
don't mind I would love for you to kick
it off and tell me whether or not you
think the 42% of Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong is the 42%
wrong absolutely it's wrong okay
absolutely I mean now I'm not saying we
need to bump it up to 80s or 990s see I
am but we'll get there
70s I think 70s is a perfectly
appropriate place I I do think this
movie was swallowed up by the like the
wave of Fantastical movies that came out
in the 80s you know the The Willows the
dark crystals the never- ending stories
those are more explicitly fantasy a
little bit more light-hearted more fun
this one is definitely more abstract a
little bit more but all those except for
Dark Crystal I think got rotten scores
too I know Willow is Willow's in our
book oh interesting well but Willow has
a great following they made a sequel
Dark Crystal got a sequel Legend I don't
see a legend sequel happening anytime
soon I don't think you're going to see a
legend sequel anytime soon but I think
Joe hit on a key a key word there that
that's going to be a recurring theme
when we get into movie talking that's
it's the abstract nature of the
storytelling I think really detracted
for me so for me I think Rotten Tomatoes
nailed it baby wow this movie is also in
the book Rotten movies we love and it's
it was 36% of its manom meter back when
the book was published now it's crawled
up to 42% and I'm just here saying all
right let's just pump the brakes on that
on that upgr I think it's right at home
with the late 30s early 40s kind of
rating I did not did not grabbed by this
movie I am not going to lie to you now
maybe it's that we live in California
and I got to enjoy certain things the
last time I got to see this it's all I
will say uh I actually recently saw this
they had one of these rep screenings at
the Beverly I saw it like maybe like two
months ago so I saw it on a theater
green it was amazing I loved it I may
have been enjoying the fact that I live
in California and things are legal it's
awesome I love this movie so much and
I'm going to go ahead and say it now I
waited I have a tattoo not quite
completely finished this is the part of
this tattoo that I don't like to talk
about is my very nice Austin tattoo guy
that I got right at the beginning of the
pandemic to like start this for me I
have not been able to get back to like
sit in his chair cuz you have to like
get on a plane afterwards it's a lot
it's a lot more like whatever so but I
do have a tattoo of this movie on here
and it is of the girl dancing in this
movie it is her it is her dress in a
ball yeah only have the ball no no it's
just got his fingers it's got his
fingers and that's the part that's not
finished is his fingers she and the ball
are finished and then it's just like
open for where the fingers are going to
be I got to get the fingers in there I
feel like some of the best tattoo
stories start with it's not finished yet
it isn't it's like you got to sit for
like 3 days like the ball is finished
that's a lot of work yeah it's a lot of
work it's not just a college mascot no
it really isn't and it's like 10 hours
each session like or six hours really
but I had no idea that you I've I've
known you for years I had no idea that
you had a as many tattoos as you
actually had but also I had no idea that
Legend was one of them Legend is one of
them yeah there was three movies I felt
strong enough that I wanted on my body
and this was one of them I love this
movie it seems like you you you side
with Joe maybe even more violently than
Joe oh way more than I would definitely
put this above certified fresh I love
this movie it is Mystical it is
wonderful I defin def appreciate some of
the warts of it but it's so lyrical it's
about this Fable of good versus evil and
balance I mean when I look at some of
the movies that were successful of this
time I don't know how you could look at
this one and be like this is so far off
from something like the never- Ending
Story like you know what I mean it has
that same level of heart I think the
worst thing that happened to this movie
is the score that people saw that went
with this movie was not the score that
worked the best for it and I still stand
by that oh like it changed the entire
tone and of the movie to have the cuts
that originally they had on this but
we'll get to that when we get into movie
talk so I think we've all decided where
we are on that one let's go ahead and
take Tim our review curation manager for
us a trip on what exactly the critics
were saying at the time in 1985 and it
seems like a little bit later for legend
so here we go with two minutes with Tim
two minutes with Tim Tom Cruz's meteoric
rise to superstardom in the 1980s goes
something like this he went went from
the Brash newcomer of Risky Business and
All the Right Moves to the box office
champ of Top Gun the color of money and
yes cocktail to the serious actor of
Rainman and born on the 4th of July all
of which makes Legend a genuine Oddity
in Tom Cruz's career Ascent his first
sci-fi fantasy film and his first
commercial disappointment as a leading
man debuting in the US a month before
Top Gun Legend was number one at the box
office for two weeks then proceeded to
sink like a stone ending up below even
Howard the Duck in the yearend box
office tally and critics weren't exactly
big fans either largely finding Legend
to be visually striking but narratively
inert Legend is rotten at 42% on the
Tomato Meter with 45 reviews and it has
a 73% audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a rotten review
William wolf of Ginette news service
wrote its production design special
effects and overall look can't be
faulted but it's hack story about good
versus evil is so insane ipid and dull
that no matter how much one might
applaud the visual achievement the movie
is still a gigantic bore however in a
fresh review Roger hbert of the South
Florida Sun Sentinel wrote It's all
Flash and no flesh but in the hands of a
visual director like Scott sometimes
that's enough the Rotten Tomatoes
critic's consensus reads not even Ridley
Scott's gorgeously realized set pieces
can save Legend from its own toddy tail
though it may be serviceable for those
simply looking for Fantasy eye candy so
that's Legend let's Ki it back to
jacqulyn mark two people for whom this
podcast holds more magic than any Palace
in the world back to you folks oh my God
for all the shade you threw on this
movie I love look look at this just look
at this right here look at these this
this couple and tell me that you do not
want to fall in love with this Tim is
just doing his job he's reporting what
the critics had to say you know what
you're going to get me like angrier than
a Reddit poster about this cuz I
literally I love this movie I think it
is yes it is fantasy schlock but at that
time what they were able to create this
was basically Tom Cruz the production
design folks and Ridley Scott in a
freaking like open air basement making
this movie and it still felt like you
were going into this fantasy world it
still felt so immersive and if you just
give yourself over to it I do think it's
an impressive bit of World building
there's things that I love about this
movie that we'll talk about that I
appreciate but there's a lot I just
can't really get behind you know what I
do feel like this is one of those ones
where like me and you are not so far
apart on movies and this is going to
hurt me a lot but you know what we'll
get to it in movie talk so let's cue the
music
[Music]
Brian no this is good we we normally
have a similar opinion I think on movies
as far as where they need to be and so
for me to love this one so much and for
you to basically treat it like a baloney
sandwich like it hurts that it does feel
like a baloney sandwich though in that
I'm not getting the substance that I
need out of this there's so much in the
world I love the Practical effects I
love I love the 80s look of it I love
that they basically built this forest in
Pinewood Studios that was used for like
a bunch of James Bond movies and stuff
like that that it does feel like its own
universe and that's so exciting but I
just the actual storytelling there's
there's nothing to glom on to there
there's nothing it's so easily good
versus evil so I know who I'm supposed
to root for but I'm not really sure why
I'm pulling for any of these people I I
didn't find anybody necessarily likable
until my favorite character in the movie
shows up Gump the elf Gump comes full
piss and vinegar and just ready to go
and like I was ready to run through a
brick wall for Gump yeah nobody elome uh
that's not the voice obviously of the
actor and I forget the voice actor um
that voiced that one but that that was
something that they did later like they
added in the voice post production post
production you would have pulled me well
it was a Darth Vader moment all right so
what did you specifically like about the
film Joe like what was your favorite
part about it and and what maybe made
you think like I see why this is rotten
I mean I think Mark kind of hit on the
head in terms of visually this movie is
almost unparalleled for the time it's in
I mean when you look at movies like
Willow and Dark Crystal they all look
cool never St look cool they have a very
like nice F fantasy element to it but
not like legend legend feels like you're
in this like wood forest with the
Sprites and elves and it feels like
you're you know with Big D in the
darkness with him in his you know his
castle um it really does feel like
you're immersed in this world but unlike
its you know its cohorts at that time it
is the abstractness of it is can be
tough for some people and I I get that I
don't I don't mind it but there is no
like a princess saying you have this
quest to go finish you know even there's
not even that many like big sword fights
there's like maybe one big sword fight
with some ogres yeah but it's a you know
fairly tame in terms of like action
there's no big action set pieces um
there's no horse like never in a story
you know that dies in The Swamp of
sadness or there I mean we watch a
unicorn get say we watch a unicorn die
yeah but resurrected at some point so
you know there you know that consequence
is kind of gone but when the one unicorn
is like just like doing laps around the
other Frozen one oh God and then also
what happens to Lily what happens to
Lily is a death in a way like her
capture and her sort of like metamorphis
look I enjoy the simple Fable aspect of
it because again it is able about trust
in the end you know it's it's the LA
lesson that Jack learns at the very end
of the of the movie that you're supposed
to get to no it's not high stakes but
it's pretty and it's so much fun and I I
do think a simple Fable doesn't make it
worse would I have liked to have seen a
more
complicated um thoroughly realized like
completely Rich Vivid idea of like
exactly what you're fighting for for
sure but the lack of that doesn't make
me enjoy this any less it's more the
lack of Personality that I found that
takes away from this movie because
Jack's personality or lack of Jack's got
nothing going on there's nothing in the
head over there got and and and Lily's
got very little going on as well she
just kind of loves traing around in the
woods ruining the this unicorn's life
for everybody I want to touch the
Unicorn whoa whoa I just showed you
where mythical unicorns live be happy
with the birds I view she's going walk
up to this thing and touch it and
everything about her says that she was
of her time an extreme Rebel like
everything just her friendships
everything that she was doing the one
thing I will give you as much as it
pains me to say it Tom Cruz is the
Achilles heel of this there's nothing
going on with the guy he he is the
Achilles teal of this tale I do not
doubt I do not deny it and I think that
was also part of it is that imagine will
you know what I mean like Will Smith or
one of those big movie stars at the
height of their power putting up a
chunker like this you know what I mean
like this is like Jim Carrey when he did
the Cable Guy it doesn't matter if we
look at it favorably later it was not
what people wanted of you yeah and and
you look at Tom Cruz's ascent and
obviously this movie comes out a month
before Top Gun and so I think that
that's where people saw his trajectory
going but I mean again even now just
putting eyes on this I am such a fan of
Tom Cruz and his filmography that this
was like an exciting thing to hit play
on because it's it's totally I've never
seen Tom Cruz like this before and I
don't necessarily blame him as a
performer as much as I do it really
seems like he was handcuffed by the
script and by the way the story is told
is that they just give him nothing to
work with like even mowley in The Jungle
Book talking to animals had way more to
do Tarzan way more to do and and even
you get to see a sense of where they're
coming from you get a sense of what
their purpose is I mean just watching
how Frozen Jack was in this film when
Lily starts to approach the unicorn and
he's like terrified he's like no no no
but he doesn't run out and stop her he
doesn't he's just sitting there just
kind of like Spellbound sitting on the
toilet and that's how I feel like his
character is throughout this entire
movie is there's just nothing really for
him to do other than just be this feral
kid running around showing everybody the
ropes let's look at rley Scott at that
time though because like this is the guy
that was doing Blade Runner and Aliens
those are not very talk this was not his
talky time of him being a director he
was the guy that put a journey of a sort
of guy on his quest you know what I mean
like that's what all of his movies were
at that time I don't know what what do
you I think that's more of a symptom of
the way Ridley operates I I think you
already said that but I'm saying like
the way Ridley wanted the story to tell
it wasn't that he didn't want it to have
that it's just that's just not the type
of movies he makes well it's it's
interesting to note that in this the
chronology of Ridley Scott is that
obviously he had alien in 79 and then he
had Blade Runner in 82 he's on this
movie he's coming off of having shot
that 1984 Apple commercial for the Super
Bowl got directed that feels like
something so violently different than
what he just came from from this scary
Overlord future selling computers so now
let's just get the hell away from
everything that has to do with Earth
maybe how much of it is yes you know Tom
Cruiser and cartwheels in the in the
woods is is may be fun for a little bit
but how much of it is that he's paired
against Tim Curry who is living it up
maybe the best part about movie and so
like we get this like magnificent really
gargantuan performance from Tim Curry
and then we get Tom Cruz you know
jumping over a sword and then maybe
punching over face you think he even
knew that though because Tim Curry's
like off to himself just basically
talking to the voice which a lot of that
was added all of that was sort of like
something that they came to later
because I think originally in the script
there's a great uh featurette I have
several copies of this a great
featurette with Tim Curry where first of
all they show his transformation and the
like this is back in the old school
makeup days when like that stuff like
basically ate your face 5 hours of
makeup and I was reading a story that
apparently like he got claustrophobic
after you know days and weeks of doing
this he tried to get the makeup off too
fast and ended up peeling some of his
skin off too so he had to sit out for a
week like to let his skin grow back like
that's the makeup was gnarly back like
they've gotten better now to where like
these are less in fact I talked to the
guys from Coming to America cuz they
obviously in the first Coming to America
they all transformed and d and then when
they did the sequel I was like what's
the biggest difference and Areno told me
he's like it doesn't hurt he's like that
used to hurt like you would take that
off and you were down for like two days
he's like if you see why Simeon
disappears so much that was probably a
day after I had to do the
makeup I was like yeah Simeon kind of
comes in and out they bled for those
Barber sh you know they really did and
he's like and that's the reason why also
you know you see Eddie all of his stuff
was filmed at the end MH H well I mean
we look at the movie even in like if
they're not in the same room you just
get this like really great performance
from Tim Curry I also really like uh the
Goblins we'll have to talk about them in
a second maybe or now they had a good
time they did I just say like favorite
characters no go right really wish uh I
knew what happened to them uh Plick and
plunder we know happens to plunder but
Plick and pox I think it's the other one
they're just gone I I mean you're you're
the legend expert if you could give me
some insight on where they go what
happens to I think they get into that
last fight and then they kind of they're
they're a boss that got defeated like
they're off you know kind of looking
their wounds I really missed them they
were really fun but it's just we get
this movie with all these really fun
characters now the Goblins the elves
Gump and uh what's the other ones names
I always forget like Murphy Brown or Tom
Brown or uh Tom Brown Tom brown brown
all close you know all these interes I
literally was thinking I was like Tom
Brown like the clothing line that is so
hilarious it's funny cuz the movie that
this beat opening weekend of the box
office cuz as Tim said it did have a
nice couple weeks there at number one it
beat a movie called Murphy's Law I think
oh interesting that was the other new
movie of the week and then you had uh
this is the 80s were just a great time
for screw ball comedy kids The Money Pit
Police Academy 3 and uh and there was
and gung-ho starring Michael Keaton
rounded out the top five opening weekend
of this movie however those three comies
I just listed all had bigger runs at the
box office they all made more cuz Legend
only pulled in about 15 million no it
only pulled in 15 million for a $24
million budget all of that was in props
production and set design because
obviously they were not the other thing
i' I think about this one you think
about Ridley Scott and how much he's
known for like big action sequences
whatever that is really what got
hamstring by this budget of this movie
like they couldn't really invest in the
stunt performers or any of that stuff
did you feel like that was missing would
you have liked to have seen a more
action heavy version of this cuz I
didn't but then I look at something like
Willow were like Val Kilmer is basically
turned into an acrobat you know and I'm
like that would have been fun yeah I
mean I think that I don't think it it's
like the biggest detriment to this movie
I think it it adds to it especially when
you compare to something like Willow or
the other movie Princess Bride which is
you know really heavy in the sword play
it would have been fun to see a little
bit more action because the majority of
the action is Tom Cruz jumping over a
sword then punching an ogre in the face
and then running around it feels like
everybody's kind of running around with
their heads cut off for a few seconds I
am actually didn't need more action in
this I just needed a little more
Direction because I felt like I was put
in the middle of this world and I almost
felt like I was a tourist just kind of
like looking it an exhibit and like you
care where Cinderella is whenever I'm
done I I can just leave and like
nobody's going to car either like I was
just kind of observing being here and
I'm sorry I know these are Big Stakes
here I know we're dealing with the light
in un the whole light of the universe is
in these two steeds and we got to at
least keep one of them alive I I never
really felt like dark taking over would
have been the worst thing it seemed like
they were having a good time oh my God
they were having a good time down there
it might be the Billy Joel I'd rather
laugh with the Sinners and cry with the
Saints the Saints ain't having a lot of
fun in this movie the one saint that
tried to do something fun was me and
Sarah and by touching a unicorn we saw
how that worked out so I might just be
on team Darkness here no I could be a
good Goblin what about the cool place
where like they go and they have like
the what sort of looking for like with
the baking and the nice lady and all
that beautiful the whole thing is
beautiful
and again team elf because I I really
thought when the elves showed up I at
least got a little kick I I I got some
juice going again because those elves
are those elves do not mess around
they're on missions man what did you
think about horny una she una is a
romance novelist uh at heart because let
me tell
you only in romance novels in the middle
of those perilous situations with the
girl be like Kiss Me Kiss Me Jack I
figured it out Joe we solved it fig out
only why jacquin loves this movie why
she adores it so much there's a tattoo
on her body upset movie is that you take
this globe that they put us in and
there's so much room there's Rich
fertile soil for your romantic novels to
that you read at the beach to grow from
here I mean I read them everywhere
listen and honestly yes the fantasy
genre that I was first exposed to was
very much like bodice rippers with
Wizards are we sure it's not unaa tattoo
on your back no I am not una no not her
we are so much better you know this
movie this movie is basically a 90minut
version of that scene in Step Brothers
where she's imagining running into John
C Ry as a centaur in the woods somewhere
that's what this movie is to be uh maybe
you know what I would write it better if
that was the case it would be way way
more detailed I will tell you you
wouldn't have problems with that plot
you
know watching this I'm watching this
movie and and I'm thinking like cuz I
always like to be like okay is was there
a specific audience in mind Geared for
this because it may not be the 43y old
dude that I currently am watching this
and so like like you were saying Joe we
all have that phase at least when we're
kids a lot of folks as as adults too
love these kind of movies and I'm not
expecting like a sweeping scope Epic
film like a Lord of the Rings when I put
this on but I'm thinking like I I don't
know that kids would have really signed
up for this because it is
it's of He-Man It's not necessarily slow
it's not plotting He-Man didn't do well
I mean they totally butchered He-Man as
we talked about this the same time this
he was 87 and you also have Billy B
starring in both this and He-Man Billy
B's best role in the mid 80s though is
unfortunately neither one of these
movies it's playing Rumple still skin
yeah because that's like that's
everybody knows the Rumple stillin story
kids going to show up to that as opposed
to Masters of the Universe which doesn't
take the war seriously at all and then
here where we're building lore but we're
not really using a lot of excitement W
with our protagonist to do it with your
love of this movie is I just couldn't
find a protagonist to get behind I'm I'm
rooting for Tim Curry you're rooting for
Tim C rooting for Darkness baby it's not
the couple it's not the couple like the
mayor and the and the stallion or like
Jack give me Tim Curry and his host of
goblins and minions all day long that's
like Jack Sparrow and the couple from
Pirates of the Caribbean there's the
vill and then there's the young couple
how do you not understand this okay if
this couple here if Lily and Jack had a
tenth of the personality chemistry any
of the relationship we
SE one may not have had personality she
had personality they had chemistry it's
just he didn't have singular did they
last do you think they last well what
cut are we talking about which ending
well I mean because there is a
director's cutor which I'm told is
different and that's the oh well yeah
it's like 20 more minutes yes Cruz has
said they like look if you're going to
see Legend see the director I think rley
Scott has said the same thing so they
both really endorse that version more
than the one that I saw go ahead with
the director's cut I'm very curious on
your thoughts on it so the director's
cut the big difference is that in the
original cut they end up together very
classic fairy T they kiss they're
together the end credits role director's
cut she gets her come up in more she
wakes up she like oh it's a dream she's
like you know what we're not really
alike at all you go back and do
cartwheels in the forest I'm going to go
do my own thing there you go and that's
how it ends which I think is a much more
appropriate ending for this movie it's
much more real ending because she was
just messing around with the other with
with the kid from the other side of the
tracks let's be honest I I would say it
to this she was just having her Thrills
before she gets married to some boring
guy sure yeah her do what she wants this
is what I was saying she's always been a
rebel and that was this whole adventure
shows her comeuppance for trying to be a
rebel like all of the death and
destruction that she caused that's what
I look at it as she plays this out in
her head and sees if I keep trying to
Rebel this is what I'm going to end up
doing like a fish and a a fish and a cat
can fall in love but where they build
their house type of situation like she
it's it's very like La La Land never
heard that one before I've never heard
did you just make that taking that a
fish and a cat can fall in love but
where they build their house or fish in
a bird is another one no that's so keep
it fish and cat that is so deep I'm just
like I don't know where they
build house I care more about the fish
and the cat will yeah more chemistry so
this is like not my saying the internet
is going to be like she's passing this
off like she is so brilliant my
grandma's been saying that since God was
a boy anyway listen I yeah no I do think
that that's that's exactly what she does
she realizes sort of like the Folly of
her because this girl is like again
maybe I've read too many period pieces
but I realized she is an unwed woman out
in the middle of nowhere that is danger
danger Dr Spock she's doing all kinds of
things she's frolicking with the little
boy in the forest I especially back then
because she's running I never really
understood towards beginning of the
movie when she goes to this little
village and she's visiting with n and
she messes with Nell's laundry it's like
distract her so she can like go like eat
a biscuit but then Nell comes in and
she's like and they're friends I'm like
why are you distract she's like the lady
why you making life harder for everybody
so there's like a big Lord on the castle
and she's either the daughter or one of
the ladies she's of importance she's one
of those people and this is just she's
gonna be assigned to marry some duke or
Noble and it's not going to be Jack yeah
this girl is just like the village chick
and Jack is basically like the dude from
Titanic how can y'all get into Titanic
and not which dude from Titanic Jack
from Titanic he is Jack is Jack from
Titanic okay okay yeah like it's like
literally the same story as like that
and y'all buy that we need to have a
disaster in the middle the boat the boat
has to sink are we comparing Tom Cruz's
chemistry in this movie with Kate I'm
just defending this so hard but that's
literally the same idea like the rich
girl but say like you didn't know what
this is I'm like there's plenty of
movies that this mirrors that you've
witnessed I'll give you Twilight because
I feel like this could have been
marketed towards a similar demographic
as Twilight because Twilight was going
after you know obviously everybody who
read the book but also trying to get
like that teenage demo in and I feel
like you could have had that if there
was more Sparks or even just like more
exchanges between Jack and Lily like
they they their relationship never got
to that level where it even felt
marketable at to anyone it's a s 93%
audience score like people are with me
on this I know I I'm I'm not saying that
I'm I'm the majority opinion know what
it is this movie went to also I want to
talk about why this movie got the
receptions that it did because it did so
many dumb things first of all they
locked Ridley out of the edit Bay never
a good idea uh the score the story of
the drama of which score is supposed to
be attached to this movie is like worse
than like Joan Crawford and Davis it's
like crazy Feud type stuff the original
score that the studio wanted was with
Jerry Goldsmith right the score with
Tangerine Dream because he's the more
established like this guy makes movie
but the Tangerine Dream one more fits to
the Ethereal sort of like fairy tale
aspect of this the entire picture also
when they were doing the whole debate
about what the director's cut was going
to be versus what the theatrical cut was
going to be the theatrical cut is the
one with Tangerine Dream because Jerry
wouldn't go back and do the crappy like
shorter version that they wanted to do
for that and so I think the Tangerine
Dream is the actual better score and I
do think the studio was right on that it
just unfortunately underscores the worst
story and the director wasn't on board
with that cut and so now you have a cut
that was originally over two hours yeah
and then it kept getting trimmed down to
the point where they were testing it and
it just kept getting shorter and shorter
and shorter until it got to like this 89
90 minute run time and look it that's
more than enough time for me anyway to
build a world because what I appreciate
about this is that it's pretty much
Ridley Scott's imagination like I'm
going to build this myth from scratch
right and I don't need like built-in IP
to go see a movie and enjoy it but I
feel like a lot of the the elements of
this were half-baked where it it never
it wasn't fully fleshed out it's granted
again you're building something new you
don't really know what you have I'm not
sure how long it took for tolken or
Lucas to like create their worlds a lot
longer than this I would right a lot no
he didn't have respect for the he did
have respect for the World building he
didn't have respect for the storytelling
you had to put towards that World
building he just wanted the visuals to
tell took the Bible a while to get rich
you know a while and even that mythology
well sometimes there's questions I think
you can say it's a little bit derivative
in terms of it's you know story there's
nothing about it that's uniquely Legend
maybe like the Lord of Darkness but very
simple uh you have a a wild boy the the
the innocent girl and evil you know
unlike you know something like never
heard story where you have like at least
a bunch of creatures you have a guy
who's a mountain out of a dragon lady
out of the water there's plenty of
people that pop a hag she a a swamp hag
which is I think also very just you know
derivative of fairy tales but it's it's
it's really small scale compared to so
much of its peers which I think that's
it's just unfortunate that it gets
compared so much to all the fantasy
movies CU compared to everything else
it's it's tiny you get this little you
two two settings really if I went to a
nice fun exciting restaurant I went to
Rainforest Cafe right and I'm there with
Joe and Jack with my dear friends I'm
GNA have a great time because the
restaurant's cool and the company's
great this is going to Rainforest Cafe
with two of the most boring people you
could possibly meet and the one is
making very questionable decisions and
the other one is just there and I'm like
yeah it's cool being at a Rainforest
Cafe like I like looking at all the
stuff there's nothing going there's no
I'm not having a good time at this table
the the environment I'm in is cool but
at the actual table my the bill can't
get here fast enough wow man that's a
lot to be said we have to get out of
here on the movie talk section because
we honestly I feel like I try to be
convincing Mark of the merits of this
movie for forever and I almost get a
tattoo of Gump the elf that's how much I
like Gump Gump Gump had a look he was
fres injection of energy into this movie
serving and absolutely fierce the other
thing I will say we didn't necessarily
talk about which is whether or not this
can be remade I'm just gonna go ahead
and give us our thing no because Tim
Curry was too good and nobody is going
to like try to top that both and like
the shape of his face and everything
that he did in that nobody's going to
try and do Darkness imagine how weird it
would be if they remade this movie but
like they they had Tom Cruz make a cameo
oh my God no if Willow can't be
successful and if Dark Crystal can't be
successful with remakes there's there's
no world where legend gets a remake and
is successful the one movie I would say
maybe like still has that sort of name
brand value would be Labyrinth from this
time yeah I and I don't I'm sure there's
been talks about it I I prefer to leave
Labyrinth where it is because Dangerous
Game hard to recreate David Bowie and
and Jennifer Connelly and the magic of
that movie and and again Labyrinth is
great like if I was looking at something
like Legend I'd be like yeah you can
punch that up a little bit Labyrinth is
pretty much perfect as is I mean you say
that but there're may I would just
remind you yesterday I looked at a new
trailer for Wonka so who are we fighting
Wonka right now no I'm saying that like
I thought that role was Untouchable and
that they would never ever try to remake
it and do anything else with it like
it's just I used y both that that that
deep into in Paul King I trust Wonka
okay look the guy made Paddington and I
know you guys want to worship him but I
want to remind you Brad bird made some
of the greatest animated movies ever and
the minute he tried to make a live
action it did not go well so that is
going to be it for movie talk we're
going to bring it over to open up our
mailbag
it's a good movie talk you know a good
movie a little you know got a little
contentious there you know what lot of
opinions flying around there's there's
passion say the guy who brought the
contention you know what though it's
actually good because again very rare
that we don't like have at least I think
a similar opinion but it's okay I'm
happy to be the darkness of this SE I
mean let's just get some Van Halen
concert movies out here where we can
really have a real debate on Whose
passion will come through oh all right
here we go from ketchup crew member
Brian cat lazan sorry Brian if I got
that wrong cast cast okay castlin good
one Mark and jacine I'm devoted member
of the ketchup crew and I wanted to
suggest the good son from 93 creepy mcau
yes this movie that has haunted me my
entire life and made a lasting
impression it doesn't sit right with me
that has a 25% critic score 54% audience
score I can't believe the only one get
behind this classic I think people
weren't ready for M col as an omen type
kid coming off the Home Alone movies
hope this movie could get a reprisal on
RT is wrong love the podcast and
appreciate your time Brian I agree I'm
with you on that one 25 I can't I that
was I can't believe the good son is that
lowly rated another Jim Carrey moment
they wanted him in other things like you
don't make the cute kid kill people okay
so I saw the good son in theaters when
it came out and I was like you know 12
or 13 I was like maybe a year older than
mcau himself and you knew that it was
going to be something different like
nobody's walking in that movie like
hoping to get yuck you knew that this
was like a Twist and a turn and that's
what we were excited about and I crap
yall not I was explaining the ending of
this movie to a couple of uh my friends
at the gym that I work out at and they
had never seen it they never heard of it
and I was explaining how the ending
plays out and their jaws were on the
floor and I'm not that good of a
Storyteller that's just like how this
movie ends up it's just like one of the
alltime coners has Cinema Joe seen this
I actually have not seen I've seen it
but I don't remember the ending the only
thing I remember remember the ending I
don't remember the ending the only thing
I remember was trick-or treat I remember
trick- or- treat and I remember him like
faking that he wasn't going to pull him
up and I remember that Elijah Wood out
cuted mcau caulin in it which is a hard
thing to do like is pretty cute he was
so like I was like oh you had to find a
kid more adorable than mcau and you did
all right we might have to get this on
the docket Brian we might have to have
Joe come back he never seen it going in
blind great recommendation Brian Cinema
Jo sir thank you so much for coming back
I really do appreciate it anywhere folks
can find you why don't let us know yeah
thank you for having me I'm glad we got
to talk about Legend and how good it is
I'm still on the pro side it may may
seem like I was on the contentious side
I'm So Pro it has it has warts but I
just don't care because I love it beauty
marks uh but yeah you can find me on
social media Cinema Joe on all social
media handles and my podcast house
Cinema podcast on all podcast
applications all right so uh tattoos
what's jacquin's got a movie themed
tattoo all of mine are movie themed okay
what's what what's the what's the the
forearm one look so this one is from
everything everyone once I uh I said on
Twitter I would get it tattooed if
Michelle yo won best actress and the
internet caught it so I was like well I
can't I can't not get it now so I got it
uh I got Tron legacy here I'm a big Tron
guy big Tron guy uh my first tattoo was
Interstellar just a morse code was
random night in Portland that's fun nice
uh then we got arrival over here big Ral
fan drive and it just goes up get The
Shining up there old boy up here damn
see now feel left I want to get a movie
tattoo what what's my movie theme tattoo
a legend you should yeah Legend no I'll
get gum on the shoulder right no I have
I have a legend the one I want to get is
the only one that I would get with color
and that's Heathers oh okay is there
like a scene or a person uh croquet and
the blue scrunchie all right good yeah
just like everything in Black and White
except for the red croquet and the blue
scrunchie I might do a sleeve and it's
just going to be Christian Slater
Through The Years there you
go that's what that's what I'm going to
do I love love CS man absolutely insane
all right real quick since you are
definitely Cinema Joe I'm sure you have
some Cinema to recommend is there
anything you want to recommend sir yes
of course so by time this episode
releases the world I'm hoping is seeing
kill as a flower Moon uh if you're not
don't be scared of the runtime yes it's
long it goes by quick I think so uh
there are some timely uh bathroom breaks
you can take but go see it all right I
would say don't wait for uple TV go see
them theaters I think that's a good
recommendation especially since that's
the way Score says he shot it and wants
it to be seen exactly I feel like he
prefers you go seeing it exactly I do
think he definitely does I think I may
have read that somewhere just uh
anywhere yeah no I saw that one it can
it is definitely going to be a huge one
to part of the conversation I'm wishing
Lily the best of luck did you see when
evil lurks at Fantastic Fest uh I saw
before then because that was also I
think at uh can I think it was at Tiff
PR TI it was TI if you need a spooky
recommendation when evil lurks we hit
shudder on the 27th M best horror movie
The Year I'll say that right now I I
agree although I will say the best
horror show that I was watching was
House of Usher I loved house haven't
started it yet that's so sure yeah maybe
I'll book myself a room at the Equinox
hotel for a weekend and just do nothing
but binge watch that Halloween weekend
if you want to set yourself up with some
I know you like to get the spooky beers
your spooky beer you put on the House of
Usher get yourself some get yourself
some candy corn popcorn you'll be you'll
be at home yeah well that's like
Halloween you know I'm a candy cor I got
problem candy I knew this again we've
been doing this a while I know we had
somebody else disgusted by our like of
candy corn yeah yeah it was great
talking to you guys I know it was great
talking to you too awesome seeing you
thank you so much thank you again on
behalf of Brian Perez Mark Ellis of
course Cinema Joe please check him out
on his podcast and our entire Rotten
Tomatoes crew Mark what are we talking
about next week well you talk about
personality we're going Adams Family
Value
use family an all time Banger just like
MC Hammer's theme for the first movie
was that we're going to 1993 for that
one Adams Family Values cannot wait to
talk about this movie absolutely this is
definitely putting us right in the
spooky coming up on Thanksgiving season
that's exactly where it should be that's
it for us this week on Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong we will see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye
[Music]
know